gli scherzetti Soprattutto se sono di
Halloween E io sono pronta a
[Musica]
vincere io sono
Frankenstein e sono qui per vincere il
titolo di re di Halloween e il libro di
Anita con i suoi poteri Ciao io sono
brom brom e ovviamente sarò io il re di
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Halloween Io sono strega Alice e vincerò
io il libro di Anita Stories e diventerò
la regina di Halloween e noi siamo Anita
e Vitale e anche noi Speriamo di
diventare la regina e il re di Halloween
e dobbiamo anche proteggere i poteri del
mio libro La città stregata che è ora
disponibile in libreria e onl se non ce
l'avete ancora andate a prenderlo subito
e noi siamo i lupi Lexi e Lex ovviamente
qui per vincere il titolo di Regina e Re
di halloweenowe ma anche il libro di
Anita Sì oggi mega Challenge di
Halloween dolces Oh
cheo Come funziona la Challenge di oggi
sarà un dolcetto o scherzetto in cui
ogni personaggio con il proprio
secchiello dovrà raccogliere più
caramelle possibile alla fine della
Challenge chi avrà più caramelle vincerà
la Challenge e il mio nuovo libro La
città stregata che è ora disponibile
online in libreria andate subito a
prenderlo ma non è finita qua perché se
due personaggi si incontreranno Chi ha
più caramelle dei due potrà chiedere
dolcetto o scherzetto se la l'altra
persona risponderà a dolcetto dovrà
consegnargli tutte le caramelle Se
invece risponderà scherzetto Sarà
costretta a subire uno scherzetto e chi
vincerà questa Challenge diventerà il re
o la regina di Halloween 3 2 un
[Musica]
via Mi raccomando fratellone Non fare il
solito pipone dobbiamo vincere noi
questa volta Ma certo che vinceremo noi
sarò coraggiosissimo Questa volta e e e
poi prenderò talmente tante caramelle
che nessuno potrà farmi nessuno
scherzetto Va bene ok Io vado di là e io
vado di là devo trovare qualche
caramella Certo però che in questa
Challenge ci sono delle strane creature
un po' mi fanno paura
ma Eh ma
quella è una
caramella
una caramella una
caramella Oh no dolcetto scherzetto
tocca a me chiedertelo perché io ho già
trovato molte caramelle e invece tu non
ne hai neanche una Oh no sono già nei
guai e va bene e allora
scherzetto Allora scherzetto Beccati
questo Ah che schifo un ragno ah
Ah uno in meno sono sempre più vicina al
mio titolo di Regina di Halloween e a
vincere il libro di Anita dai Vitale da
che parte
Andiamo che stai facendo di là Le
caramelle sono di là come fai a saperlo
è il mio fiuto da gran mangione
modestamente Seguimi Ok allora mi
fido Dove stai andando questo sole mi dà
troppo fastidio Ah eh Eh modestamente il
mio fiuto da conoscitore di caramelle
dolcetti Trovate le prime caramelle Sì
Questa la tengo io però eh Non si sa mai
speriamo di vincere noi il titolo di
Regina e Re di Halloween Speriamo di
prendere quante più caramelle possibile
così me le posso mangiare tutte tutte
dai Anita andiamo a cercare altre
caramelle Sì sì sì dobbiamo vincere
Certo che questo sole però non ci aiuta
Eh no dà fastidio Mettiamoci Qui
all'ombra Ciao sono l'emoji di It A
proposito di lupi mannari e vampiri nel
mio nuovo libro La città stregata c'è
una trasformazione in lupo mannaro è un
mistero da risolvere se non ce l'hai
ancora Prendilo subito perché per i
primi a prenderlo ci sarà in regalo un
poster autografato e ricordati di
cliccare mi piace sotto a questo video
Prova a cliccare mi piace entro 3
secondi 3 2 1 tempo scaduto Ehi Anita ma
qui non c'è niente
Ciao io sono brom broom e sarò il futuro
re di Halloween oh mi è caduto il naso
ne ho un altro ma Allora giochiamo un
po' vediamo chi ha più caramelle tra noi
due Oh no Il pagliaccio è più caramelle
di Noi che cosa facciamo Secondo te ma
io non darei mai via le mie caramelle
quindi io sceglierei scherzetto Beh
pensandoci bene dobbiamo vincere
assolutamente che sarà mai uno
scherzetto quindi Brava Anita scegliamo
scherzetto Sì sì scegliamo scherzetto ho
sentito
scherzetto e allora
divertiamoci mi piacciono tanto gli
scherzetti Soprattutto se sono di
Halloween E allora per voi
dagno
Felice
Halloween toglilo
toglilo scappiamo
presto Scommetto che quel fifone di mio
fratello se la sarà già data a gambe
[Musica]
levate una
caramella Ecco qua ho trovato una
caramella
[Musica]
Ah che brutto Che schifo Ma cosa
è fa ancora più schifo
questo quindi adesso dobbiamo capire chi
ha più caramelle
[Musica]
Sì ho vinto io e dato che ne ho di più
cosa scegli Don Cetto o
scherzetto
Beh mostro ti è andata male perché io ho
solo una caramella e sinceramente non me
ne frega niente di perderla Ecco qua
ciao
u non è giusto devo trovare un modo per
spaventare qualcuno perché io non voglio
cercarle le caramelle voglio rubarle a
[Risate]
qualcuno ma tu sei la prego E tu sei il
pagliaccio Oh sì Dobbiamo scoprire chi
ha più caramelle va
[Musica]
bene Beh piaccio è evidente che io ho
più caramelle di te quindi dolcetto o
scherzetto OH Mannaggia Non posso
lasciare così tante caramelle anche se
sono meno delle tue quindi scherzetto
tanto non saranno mai belli quanto i
miei
Ah sì Pensi che i miei scherzi siano più
brutti dei tuoi Beh allora beccati
questo per la tua fastidiosa
risata Chi ha riso così
io non sono io
questo cosa hai fatto alla mia risata
Benti sta brutto pagliaccio e adesso
devo andare a vincere il mio titolo da
regina di Halloween
caram caram caram caram caram
caram no E tu chi sei voi dare caramelle
me voglio trasformare voi in zombie come
me intendi dire dolcetto o scherzetto sì
Insomma hai capito Beh prima dobbiamo
vedere chi ha più caramelle per vedere
chi può dire dolcetto scherzetto Gi
vediamo
siccome noi abbiamo più dolcetti di te
tocca a noi dire dolcetto o scherzetto
non me ne frega niente delle regole se
non mi date subito G dolcetti vi
trasformerò in zombie come me Ah sì
Allora se la metti così
scherzetto
l'ho trasformato in pipistrello Così
impara a voleri trasformare in
zombie Oh aspetta possiamo anche
prendere le sue caramelle Adesso è
vero Maledetti vampir Adesso vi faccio
la cacca in testa
scpp una
caramella l'ho vista prima io Non è vero
L'ho vista prima Io bene Allora vediamo
chi ha più
[Musica]
caramelle bello pacchiotta Ho vinto io
quindi dolcetto scherzetto io ho dovuto
dare l'unica caramella che avevo allo
Zombie perciò non posso dire Dolcetta
non ne ho
Allora scelgo
scherzetto bene allora un bell'
incantesimo per
te che cos'è quello un bel guinzaglio
adesso non sei più un Lupetto adesso sei
il mio cagnolino ma cane a chi guarda
che io sono un lupo mannaro Eh andiamo
no
lasciami Ma perché mi cade sempre il
naso adesso lo rimetto Oh no questa è
una
caramella Adesso va
meglio sta calando il sole meglio per
noi vampiri ci vediamo meglio al buio
Ten
Comunque siamo a buon punto abbiamo un
sacco di caramelle Falle tenere a me
però dai
[Musica]
no ciao vampiri aspettavo proprio voi
questa è la battaglia finale e io sono
pronta a
vincere Vieni qua Stai a cuccia non ti
lasceremo mai vincere strega cattiva e
poi hai pure preso la lupa Mannara con
il guinzaglio poverina dobbiamo
liberarla Sì la dobbiamo liberare Ehi
però aspetta dobbiamo prima contare le
caramelle chi ne ha di più È vero
vediamo chi può fare dolcetto scherzetto
questa volta Eh sì allora io ne
ho 4 5 6 7 io lo so già io 50
caramelle Oh no Quanto ne abbiamo noi
Noi ne abbiamo
49 no come
49 vampiri dolcetto o
scherzetto se noi diciamo dolcetto
dovremmo consegnarle tutte le caramelle
no io non le voglio consegnare tutte e
lei vincerà la Challenge Ma se noi
diciamo Scherzetto Ci eliminerà Come ha
fatto con gli altri giocatori Oh no non
ci avevo pensato quindi in ogni caso lei
vincerà non possiamo lasciarla vincere i
poteri del libro sono troppo potenti non
devono andare nelle mani sbagliate e poi
dobbiamo anche liberare Lexi cosa
facciamo fine dei giochi adesso il mio
momento è arrivato con i poteri del
libro sarò la creatura più forte di
questo mondo e sarò la regina indiscussa
di
Halloween aspetta V masticando qualcosa
Cosa hai detto Stai zitta nessuno ti ha
detto di parlare è vero Ma hai T le
caramelle in bocca smut smuta
presso due caramelle Eh sì Scus 49 50 51
abbiamo noi più caramelle della strega
quindi dobbiamo dire noi dolcetto o
scherzetto SCH 51 Ma come maledetto
Vitale io non mi abbasserò a subire i
vostri scherzi Quindi io di
dolcetto Ma sappiate che ritornerò e
prenderò tutti i poteri del
libro Sì sono
libero
Sì abbiamo fatta bravissimo Alexi Grazie
a te anche abbiamo vinto questa
Challenge la strega cattiva è andata via
per sempre forse ma abbiamo vinto E voi
se ancora non avete il libro La città
stregata cosa state aspettando andate
subito a prenderlo e ora vi lasciamo Qua
quattro Cellina su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
[Musica]
cho